well we're going to try to go to the
club without making anyways so that
means outfits drinks revelry and we're
also going to be comparing our makeup
routines and zero-waste and regular Zee
Rosi Rosi zero welcome back
wait what do we do welcome to our
displays I was explaining to Ari while
we were setting up every pregame needs a
drink
but I thought we're gonna get my pick
out my clothes we got to do that tipsy
if we start drinking now then we're
gonna be already drunk when you get
there I kind of move into like a white
wine situation with cor water we can
recycle the journals and there's no
plastic on this corpse feels classy yeah
I'm gonna be class tonight before I get
you trash trashed zero is now pretty
gaming so instead of buying something
new we're gonna be picking out each
other's outfits yes to be zero waste
because we're not banging we're not
buying anything we're just making a new
look out of things we already have yes
which fresh eyes I need you in full
thought mode not mode okay I like this
this is kind of a daytime look
no is it daytime cuz I was thinking
about cutting it down the middle you're
not cutting any my club look at this ahh
I want you try it on this looks great I
didn't know she was naked oh my god
you're so high let's do this
see look see now he needs to just put
your booty out okay there we go
so this is what number one what's a to
BC war for Halloween
oh so orange a lot yes try it on oh I
like this but
Melvyn through we hike it up hike it up
I wear this for Halloween though like I
don't think this is in every day yeah
you know what I was thinking the same I
think I just remember cuz that night we
were so tipsy what party body body body
is this the look mrs. who look okay
let's get you hoops huh
and then I get to pick out your outfit
yes so this year and I got from this
local store called sustained LA and you
can reap Dell all your products in bulk
like the in terment
and this actually works better than any
juror in my god your top your in your
bottom all right I want to address a
shiny number oh and it's interactive I'm
gonna make her try this one oh this is a
good look I like this action when do you
ever wear this like sequin number I'm
number one it really why I want you to
try it on you get to pick kind of like
what type of moment you want to be
having can you try this one on how
happening okay I want to see you in this
one two four haven't worn likes hmmm I
think this is my favorite so you just
have this in your closet and you hadn't
worn it no it's so cute I know I know I
love pockets do you like this is the
sequin one I like this one okay let's do
her makeup yeah so we're gonna compare
makeup routines purse the routine is
very simple mine is not I already have
foundation on and I don't need much
she's needed to find my eyebrows is that
what highlighter is yes um I put over my
eyebrows really never got my eyebrows
waxed
you'll also put on your cheeks yes
you'll see so because my foundation is
pretty much on I'm gonna use my summer
foundation that's a little darker than
my skin tone but through highlighter it
becomes the perfect color
I used my lipstick which comes in like a
metal tube and then I have this cake
mascara yeah it's like a little cake so
then it's in a metal tin instead of the
plastic I love your face I'm not judging
because you know I'm on my zero which
journey as well and then I just wet it
and then I use this little applicator
and I put it so I actually get water so
I need oh I reckon looks good wait
smooshy Victoria's Secret and who needs
eyeliner
oh are you happy there boys
the deep questions are you putting
yourself in positions that make you
comfortable I like that it's a check-in
and myself actually my makeup take so
long
okay so this is my club look I defined
my eyebrows put on fresh foundation
highlighted put on eyeliner highlighted
the corner of my eyes highlighted my
make up with a shimmery powder and then
made a nice hollow graphic lip look with
a little bit of my concealer woohoo and
what you do I put on some red lipstick
and some mascara
so these are final looks okay so this is
how we're actually going to be zero
waste at the club okay I have two cups
for us okay for water perfect because
usually you can get beers and cocktails
in glass at the bar but then the water
they have at the end of the bar and they
only have plastic cups menus so we have
these to avoid that single-use plastic
and then I have some cocktail straws so
we're gonna remember to say no straw
please we have her drinks and then we
have these fancy little glass straws
which I don't usually bring but you know
we're being fancy tonight whooshing
tonight you know we're trying to finesse
we're trying to clown let's go let's
have fun yeah turn four shots
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this was a very successful zero-waste
night I think we did that we only made
this one map and they are drink down on
a nap see I even feel I got to WoW but
the other one I avoid blue cake total
yeah we're going to do zero waste
Caribbean food featuring by mutual
finally
we look so cute and so attractive we do
I mean maybe and it's okay what you
can't have us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]